un second référendum sur le bauxite
c'est ce que réclame une grande campagne
lancée en avril 2018 par best of buyten
de plus en plus de voix britanniques
remettent en cause les conséquences du
premier vote
l'ortho l'afp john coeur auteur de
l'article 50 qui organise le poète site
affirme même je pense qu'il y ait
maintenant au moins 30% de chances qu'on
organise un nouveau référendum alors
divorce inéluctable ou les britanniques
peuvent ils encore et calmes et un ex
ipsum bauxite
d'abord rappelons ce cas nous excite le
mot est la contraction de 8 yens et eksi
il désigne le départ volontaire de
l'union européenne du royaume uni il a
été approuvé par référendum le 23 juin
2016 par 52% des voix contre 48
mais aujourd'hui les britanniques ne
seraient plus que 42 % à approuver ce
break site
comment expliquer ce revirement tout
d'abord il y adeux bile 50 milliards
pour le royaume uni
ensuite les anglais commencent à voir
les conséquences négatives du divorce
pour l'économie l'emploi ou même la
mobilité des citoyens
enfin il ya la révélation du scandale
cambodge analytique à cette société à
utiliser illégalement des données
privées de millions d'utilisateurs
facebook pour influencer le vote sans
cela il n'y aurait pas eu de pré site
affirment leur ancien employé certains
politiciens comme l'ancien premier
ministre tony blair estime que les
zambiens ont été induits en erreur
il plaide donc pour un nouveau vote sur
l'accord techniquement l'ortho lac john
kerr a raison selon l'article 50 le
royaume uni peut faire marche arrière
jusqu'à mars 2019
tant qu'il n'a pas signé l'accord
définitif avec les 27 pays membres de
l'union
mais politiquement les observateurs
notent sont unanimes n'y a quasiment
aucune chance qu'un second référendum
soit organisé
theresa may a indiqué clairement dès
qu'elle est devenue première ministre
que son gouvernement respecterait le
résultat du référendum
c'est grâce à la victoire du livre
qu'elle a pris la tête du parti
conservateur plis du pays et même dans
l'opposition le leader travailliste a
fait savoir qu'il ne s'opposerait pas à
la sortie
donc pour l'heure la fiom coeur dit
qu'il y à 30% de chances qu'on organise
un nouveau référendum
c'est contestable
[Musique]